so the dark side is something that I've
designed it's an evil place I can go
that very few things can hurt you stre
things that you can remind yourself of
how to embrace the pain and grow
stronger through it adults learn through
massive trauma so you will learn you
have to let in some trauma into your
life and that's rough but no pain no
gain
rise and shine it's in spresso time
what's up believe nation it's evan my
one word is believe and i believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference in the world so let's start
your day off right grab your coffee and
sip on today's message be fueled by pain
over to you David Goggins
what power have you found in the
darkness first I will be for answer that
question I want to say everybody listen
to this I'm the happiest man on the
planet Earth so people may take this and
as so many people do we live in a very
weakened society so when they hear a
throwback guy like me from back in the
ancient days of Garanimals they often
think this guy's just whatever so if you
think that I'm some unhappy guy you're
wrong
having lived a life I've lived in seeing
the other side not being afraid to
attack what was in front of me has made
me happy say that again
and in fact let me make sure I
understood it getting to the point where
you're not afraid to face the thing on
the other side of the door that wants to
attack you has made you happy right
right it's really powerful I hope people
heard that right it made me very happy
so basically I just don't walk around
with a daggone smile my face all the
time so you know Merry Christmas but but
basically what the dark side is is we
all have a cookie jar and we all have a
jar that's its official name it's a jar
of man we're just it's just ain't going
right and in hell week what they do in
hell week because this is where I really
went to the dark side we're doing hell
week as they design hell week to find
your flaws and they do a really good job
of that it's 130 hours of continuous
training you may get two hours of sleep
and they beat this either you will find
everything wrong with your mentality and
then they start hell week and that's the
beauty of it and for me I'm not some not
no nasty guy giving guy you know I don't
have a great bit of talent in anything
so what got me through horrible times
was the dark side whereas I created my
name is David Goggins I created Goggins
Goggins is the guy that can take
anything you put in front of them you
want to break my legs so be it
I have a way of going to a place like I
did in that race where all the pain and
suffering that they put on top of me in
hell week I will reverse that pain and
suffering and I will take your soul so
every instructor that put me through
budge my job what drove me was I wanted
you to go home that night after you beat
the living [ __ ] out of me and I smiled
in your face I wanted you to feel worse
than I did and you were going home to a
nice warm bed with your wife or your
kids in a nice meal and I was still out
there in the grip suffering for another
100 hours I want you to think about me
knowing that I'm comfortable being very
comfortable and I want you to think
about when you went through hell week
how uncomfortable you were and how bad
you wanted to quit knowing I'm not
thinking that way so the dark side is
something that I've designed it's an
evil place I can go that very few things
can hurt me
I used to hurt you're trying to put on
me I flip it upside down and use it
you can use it for kryptonite no it's
power pillows for me I'm using it for
strength
I flipped negative into positive Saudis
I have learned to make pain my friend I
have learned to make pain the
opportunity for me to show myself in the
world what I am made of every time I am
faced with a situation that is painful I
welcome it and I look at it and I say
this is great and I try to put a big
smile on my face to tell myself that
this is my chance to show myself and the
world what I am made of because it's
easy when it's easy it's easy to win a
race against three-year-olds it's easy
to win a spelling test against
kindergarten people right it's easy it's
easy when it's easy but the challenge is
when it's hard when it's hard is when
you grow when you're pushing your point
to failure when you're lifting weights
and your point of failure that's when
your muscles grow you want a challenge
you want to learn you want to you want
to win the big game you want to get
better growth is contagious crows growth
is
intoxicated and you get that through
pain you get that through failure I was
on two interviews today with different
youtubers interviewing for their show
and we had problems on both shows the
first one we did in a hotel room because
her studio was being fumigated and so
she's apologizing that it's fumigated
and she has to be in a hotel room and
the Lighting's not great and I said this
is the best I love this I love that
you're in a hotel room right now I kind
of hope that my microphone breaks down
and I have to pick up my phone and film
from that like I love it I embrace this
is amazing and then I had another guy
who we were on a Skype call and he was
doing it with Wi-Fi and the Wi-Fi cut
out and I'm on there by him by myself
waiting for him to come back like this
is amazing I love this the ghetto that's
the best I love it this is so awesome
and I've trained myself to do that
because I think when you expect things
not to be painful
then you set yourself up for a big loss
how do you embrace your pain becomes the
next questions like great you may start
to get what we're saying you may think
it's still crazy but you're still
tagging along the kind understand the
how here's three things that you can
remind yourself of how to embrace the
pain and grow stronger through it number
one is acknowledge and accept the pain
just acknowledging that pain will happen
that along the course of being an
entrepreneur moving to down your career
if you're pushing for something big then
you all know pain you will know failure
not everything's gonna work out if there
was no pain in your life that means you
played it so safe that you never took a
risk and that's the biggest pain of all
that's the biggest failure of all if you
want everything you ever tried it means
you didn't try enough right you're only
racing against two three-year-olds you
didn't try enough you don't know what
you're capable of because you've never
reached anywhere close to your limits
because you played life so safe so just
acknowledging and accepting that pain
will be a part of the journey and that's
okay that's expected because if you
expect no pain at all then when it comes
you can't deal with it then when it
comes you complain when it comes you
blame somebody else acknowledge it it's
coming it's coming for you it's part of
the journey is part of the process
everybody goes through it
number two is see the bright side of
pain so when the pain happens you what
are your options your pain has pain
coming on you write something negative
happened in your life in your business
the pain has come for you what do you do
you either react negatively you either
complain you blame you get frustrated
get angry
or you embrace it the pain is there
anyway you now get to choose how you
react to it so if I'm doing an interview
on the Skype call pops out or somebody's
in a dimly lit hotel room instead of
being in a fancy studio what are my
options I'm gonna walk away I'm gonna
get upset at them for not being prepared
I'm gonna blame Comcast or not having
better internet like what are my options
my approach is when the negative thing
happens this is amazing I love this this
is awesome and I changed my mindset
around it so that I'm gonna have a great
experience and if I'm with somebody else
they will too
now it's not again that I'm welcoming
pain that I'm looking forward to it I
think it's awesome when there's no pain
- it's not
you are only awesome when there's pain
no you are awesome all the time
you're awesome when there's no pain and
you're awesome when there is pain the
pain is common regardless so you get to
choose how you want to accept it if you
fight against it and you're negative it
doesn't serve anybody if you embrace it
and say this is great this is my chance
I will smile and tell myself this is my
chance to show myself and the world what
I am made of embrace it and use it to
your advantage instead of wallowing in
the negativity I win number three is to
change your environment the more you are
around people who complain about pain
people complain about the stupidest
things people complain all day long
about really really really silly things
that are insignificant that are
definitely first world problems that you
should not be complaining about you know
you have access to the Internet you you
you are healthy like you have a lot to
be grateful for instead of complaining
changing your surroundings changing your
environment to not hang around these
people as much and instead hang your own
people like David Goggins if you want to
go extreme or other people who you look
up to and respect any successful person
look at whoever you love who's had
success spend more time with them
whether it's a top 10 series meant to me
series or some other series or you're
buying their books whatever it is spend
more time with them because they do not
complain when the pain comes they
embrace it they use it their advantage
that's one of the most common
characteristics that people who have
success and so changing your environment
to stop hanging on people who are
negative and complain when the pain
comes and instead hang around even if
it's virtually with people who embrace
the pain a use of their advantage do
that on a consistent basis you will
transform your
now I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what is the single biggest pain
that you've had to deal with and how did
you get through it please share down the
comments below I want to hear your story
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
a vinspresso
and enjoy the bonus clip
[Music]
pain allows somebody to get more
disciplined okay so going back to that
myth of when you see your life and
anytime there should be paying you go no
no no no it was just how it was meant to
be
no look yourself in the mirror sometimes
and go you know why I'm not happy it's
because I didn't listen ten years ago
and I got in the wrong career you know
I'm not happy because I married the
wrong damn person it wasn't meant to
happen yes everything happens for a
reason you made a bad choice but it
didn't have to be that way and the
second you build up pain and this by the
way is not my opinion if you talk to
guys like dr. David buss top ten most
cited psychologist in history
okay he's one of my main mentors he told
me I said to adults change like we do
all this self-help videos in podcast I
said am I wasting my time he goes yeah
kind of I said why he said well after 25
it's very hard to teach old dogs new
tricks by the way that's why I've
changed most of my stuff targets people
18 to 25 that's why I do snapchat and
all that because there's hope for 18 to
25 oh now if you're over 25 before you
get depressed
he told me but I have good news for you
time I said what he said adults learn
through massive trauma so you will learn
you have to let in some trauma into your
life and that's rough but no pain no
gain like if you are a hundred pounds
overweight and you want to be able to
play basketball here's my news for you
everything happens for a reason you got
fat because you ate too much and you
didn't exercise so welcome to the gym in
the first year is gonna be hell but that
pain hopefully will reprogram your brain
at every time you want to eat that nasty
thing go wait I don't wanna go through
that pain again so I think one of the
myths of societies we won't let pain in
we just excuse it all away like nah that
wasn't meant to happen
oh you wasted 20 years of life married
the wrong person in the wrong career no
Tom it was meant to happen where's the
people who go you
you've wasted 20 years and you will
never get it back you better go in your
room and cry and the truth is you only
learn as an adult unfortunately most
people can only change with mass and
trauma
experiencing pain in your muscles and
aching and just think Oh on and go on
and go on and this last two or three or
four repetitions that's what makes
actually the muscle then grow and that
divides then one from a champion and one
from not being a champion if you can't
go through this pain period you make it
to be a champion if you can't go through
forget it
and that's what most people like isn't
this having the guts to guts to go in
and just say I go through and I don't
care what happens you know it aches and
if I fall down I have no fear of
fainting in a gym because I know it's it
could happen I threw up many times while
I was working out but it doesn't matter
because it's all worth it if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it won't you believe it you
act like it I tell so what a wail out of
handcuffed lightning though Thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I've murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access